you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on elite
chess org and I just got paired up
playing a 15-2 game against the
Combinator
okay let's try d4 and see what is thrown
my way okay
all right knight c6 let's go with let's
go with Knight to f3 and just try to
fight immediately for the same squares
he's controlling in the center
okay d6 so I'm thinking that black is
heading for a quick Bishop to g4 not the
only option
but what should I do here I'm
considering efore
c4 and drilling nothing more d5
I guess I could consider d5 but c4
seems like it fits in well let's start
with c4 it's a deep on game I like to
create this duo
I might take a bit of a reserved I
decide I'm
just keep him behind my pawn structure
so on Bishop g4 might be fine with III
Bishop to e2 Castle and may even delay
my Queen side minor pieces some
all right I think I'm on those
with staying a bit flexible
so
these squares are all
what are they going to do I want to
learn a little bit more information
about their
bishop maybe they will tell me and their
next move now
okay so heading for some kind of Kings
Indian then Bishop g7 and I guess the
only pawn push I have to be on the
lookout for the one that would make
sense is e5 of course you could play d5
but I could claim that black of course
lost a little bit of time
so
towards efore here
an e4 there
to g4
I don't want d4 to come under some heavy
fire too fast don't want to lose control
of this this point so II for Bishop g4
is already threatening to take and then
went upon e for Bishop g4 Bishop to e2
would allow a five and on a push there's
a capture then the night sinks into d4
so with this in mind
you know my concern over d4 has me
thinking more about a move like d5
instead of e4 and I think I'm going to
take this opportunity to push the night
and see where he goes I played games
maybe even though yeah I think I may
have played a standard game one that I
recorded put on YouTube where the night
plays into e5 so I have a little bit of
experience with that structure
I can't quite remember how that game
finished up but you know this is this is
something I recalled that the computer
isn't so much a fan of this for black
alright so I think I just go straight in
for the capture
I could try to play this position type
where you know I could say I have a
little bit of space so you know no thank
you
I'll just avoid the exchange and maybe
try to gain an additional strike against
this night with tempo just like I pushed
d5 with an attack I could look to play
off for with an attack against tonight I
have no concern of this because of Queen
2a for picking up the night
but I think I'm fine with simply taking
the night
and following up now with e4 this is
without question where the pawn belongs
not e3 two squares
Bishop to e2 or Bishop to d3
probably to e2 they're going to
fianchetto
I like having the bishop I'll need to to
observe these squares from the night so
night h5 to f4 maneuvers are pretty much
ruled out with the bishop on you too
anything more to consider I do have a
check in the position but
who is that really doing after Bishop to
d7
I don't think I accomplished anything
great with that check
I feel like a compute
may do something like that and then drop
back to b3 just try to strike at the b7
pawn the weak point
who question I have for myself is what
in this position am i okay with a clean
exchange yeah I usually am and I think
it it's a good idea in this position
type why exactly because this bishop
isn't really a great contributor
one of these two moves soon to challenge
this point but this pawn isn't going to
go anywhere anytime fast my plan will be
to keep him around
just maintain d5
yeah let's just go with Bishop to e2
this will be my Kings home I think it's
worthwhile to invest an additional tempo
to fianchetto him as mentioned I like
having these squares under control
not too many candidate moves for either
side in this position type I don't think
pretty normal as castle's Issa 'kx zi e6
is more likely to follow instead of c6
strike
okay well my bishop has a lot of options
but I don't really know where he belongs
but I definitely know where my king
loans
now what's popular
ask nano what
okay
I'm leaning towards this
and two options right but Bishop to g5
he'll be questioned and I think that
this is a desirable move for black have
an additional square for the King so I'm
leaning towards Bishop to e3
I could take but I don't want to do that
and help them develop Bishop III
I guess I would have a there is maybe a
reason to have considered Bishop g5 a
little bit more it's getting a super
technical with h6 dropping back and then
later on I could claim
a developing move with my queen and all
of a sudden I'm threatening to win upon
who knows computer probably be
suggesting these two moves
with equal evaluations tough to say
have a Bishop c5 move
with a punch against the rook
where does my queen belong
not sure b3 is interesting puts pressure
on b7 there's a lot of traffic on this
diagonal but is in the end opposite the
king so maybe
that will play a role at some stage okay
I'm thinking about taking towards the
center
I see no good reason not to do just that
I know
take care not just because
I would be dropping e4 but let's just
say I had f3 and I still wouldn't want
to take on d5 with the knight because
black would like to have this Knight out
of the way so that enough 5 move
can to be quick to hit notice the two
nights they're competing for these two
squares and my night is not obstructing
my upon but their knight on f6 is okay
so they're looking for nine to d6
okay how do we treat this
well there is a half-open C file so
certainly this comes to mind but what
black is lining up is Knight d6 in f5 so
how should i how should i combat this I
could I could shoot for a dark square
bishop exchange which is how to how to
say exactly I still could be pressing
for an attack against their King with
this ID and 922 Bishop h6
clean D 296 Bishop h6 f5 is maybe with
this idea to exchange dark square bishop
s-- this will discourage let's say n f5
move because they will then be without a
key King side defender and well the
Queen's are still on board and there's
still a lot of a lot of pieces around
so let's say Queen d2 Knight d6 Bishop
h6 f5 Bishop takes King takes and I may
be able to act
pretty quick in the center with f4 I
can't work out all those details just
kind of using my intuition I think that
that would be good for me
what other candidate moves I'm not
really touching on some other move
besides coming to d2
I'm going to go with Queen the d2
yeah
so here's another interesting point my
initial when I was touching on the
bishop going to g5 or e3 on its first
move
Bishop g5 h 6'i drop back Queen d2 later
King here notice ID I would have gained
a tempo with Queen to d2
but at the same time I would no longer
have the option to exchange dark-squared
bishop because the black would be in
time to not only defend h6 but simply
avoid the dark square bishop exchange
so another interesting moment should I
wait for first f5 or just go straight in
for Bishop h6
I think it's a good idea
straight in because I feel that f5 is
simply the only constructive plan for
black playing on the queenside is where
I have some space trying to crack a d5
will split the queenside structure give
me files to work with and that could
only be good for me if play follows on
the queenside I feel like I would win
out on any attempt by black to to move
the queenside pawns so my focus here is
on the kingside
it's a pretty great
move
is it a losing move
for black okay so on this they have
night takes that's the only move they're
proposing a take back
what do I do what's the story with that
trap the queen and then realize that
they have this I'm not sure maybe
they're saying something in the notes
they're just giving me a bunch of time
they cancel their own take backs off I
think baby they thought oh man my queen
is going to be trapped and then realized
wait a second I have this who knows
though okay so I got awarded some time
apparently because they three would take
back my way and then cancelled it anyhow
what should we do here well here Knight
takes pawn
let's calculate a little bit here I
might have something
Bishop g5
has one move Knight takes e4 Bishop
takes Queen Knight takes Queen this
night is really short on squares rook d1
from that position they have Bishop h6
to defend the night and from that
position
this might run pretty deep but
do I not have
f 3 within the move Bishop to e1 and I'm
winning that night
so just again I'm pretty deep now Bishop
g5 Knight takes e4 Bishop takes Queen
Knight takes Queen rook to d1 Bishop H
6f3
they can insert a check on III came to
h1 is no problem
five
bishop to e1 on takes pawn and i think
i'm just winning the night
it's a
and devoting so much time to those a
better work
one more chance boom
now I'm pulling the trigger on it
Bishop g5 Bishop g5 takes takes takes
rook here here F 3 F 5 there's even a
four moves I could take that
you
let's try it
you
oh yeah
that have to take on you for so I got
just going to play this variation out
and we're going to see where I
miscalculated it's very likely that I
did and that there's some kind of save
related to an f5 or e4 move to rescue
the knight it's close
you
surprised that their thinking here isn't
this
move bishops are controlling everything
hmm
you
maybe they're trying to us on either
they're saying my nights trapped at the
end we'll see yeah we'll see
and see the
they have
page five and my D was f3o you know it
might be more accurate
f-for come to think of it
now not quite f4 they could take and on
this there's a push hitting my bishop
and rook
so f3o you know here's another limit I'm
going to follow through with this on
this Bishop check that's no bother
actually because I can block Bishop
takes King takes and the knight is
cooked so they have to try something
with this
I think e4 actually yeah this this fi I
don't know why from that earlier
position before I played Bishop g5 I was
thinking that f5 would be something it's
just that if anything that they try e4
if I play Bishop e1 then there's III in
the knight is rescued so II for
I can always regain the pond right I'm
only this is a pawn investment and
they're struggling to get their Knight
back into the ball game
so II for
take with the pond and maybe then f5
yeah efore takes and then f5 or efore
takes rook here I do have bishop here I
think I think they'd have to get another
pawn involved it's close it's really
close to have to be accurate here one
wrong step in there piece is dead and
that'll be it so let's see what they
come up with
well it started
area positional and quiet and then we
had some critical lines show up
Queen h4 it's one of those
I don't know it you see it as like a
really aggressive move and you're
developing your queen you're throwing it
your queen in your opponent's territory
it's towards the king there's a punch
but let's see if that is actually
something
skew the night
think efore has to be played
god I at least investigated this a
little bit further because I was ready
to stop right away just after Bishop g5
I thought Knight takes e4 and oh you
know I was ready to not take that
calculation any further which is not the
right thing to do
this is running much deeper
something other than efore I mean
they're going to try Bishop f5 here and
then play Bishop here I'll be fine with
giving up the rope
for the night
yeah get the two minor pieces for the
rook okay II for it is
here just makes life too easy
I still want them to struggle this
rescue that night this thread is still
there
five right now I could scoot right by
actually acquire a passed pawn I think
it's important that blacks start with
rook to e8 here before f5 I think these
two moves will are required and move
order very important
rook here here and only then this
because I don't have the push
right here Bishop d3 f5
I could at least take and split their
structure so in the end this might just
turn out to be
me been benefitting ever so slightly
because of
well benefiting as a result of a better
structure
I say that right might be a structure
advantage for me
yup rectory 8 it is
I go all the way back Knight takes
Knight takes rook here I don't have
anything good from that all right let's
put my ooh you know what if I go here
there's Bishop g4 though I have ripped
it you won all right well at least right
now
not down at any pawn the night is kind
of still in a shaky position also my
bishop is uh I still of course want to
watch over the c-4 square that's one of
the potential escape routes for the
night my back rank my rooks controlled
these uh squares from tonight my pawns
control these
and so these are the other two
my bishop has them
big intersection square on e4 I guess
they're gearing
for f5 that's the only thing that really
makes sense here oh no no no I was
pointing out Bishop g4 so okay maybe
they're going to go with that five or
Bishop to g4
I think I'd be happy to simply duck the
threat and now on an ensuing f5 I have e
5
of course I release the pressure on the
night Bishop g4 rip to e1 but this or
could come over at some point let's just
help together by a thread so far for
black
so on f5 let's I think this is best so
let me try to work out the details with
f5 f5 probably just take
you
I wonder if I want
Bishop move here
like here I'm controlling a lot of
squares with my bishops
ooh
might be close to winning that rook
okay this time
was also opened these guys could be
knifes
knives nice yeah so Bishop to b5
is covered but I think I want to just
capture here
um
okay he's unprotected there might be
some in-between type of move end up with
an isolated pawn here they'll have
something that'll have one on the Kings
side
yeah I think I have
just take out of five I don't have
anything else to consider I mean I don't
see any other candidate move let's do it
okay so there Knight is not going to be
trapped
you
okay let's take and now what do we do
here I could I could play Bishop to e1
this Knight is soon going to be a bother
on e3 I do something like this he's
going to be a big pest
okay again down to the wire here let's
you do put two e1i you
I'm going to go into e1 I don't want to
pull my bishop off of this diagonal so
fast
my night might want to go elsewhere and
I don't want to see a quick punch thrown
in d5
so let's even
94 hits at B to Point C for B 393 I have
this there's night - C - okay King there
if I played b3
or
maybe I just immediately come back here
yeah I got to make a quick move forget
about observing da time observing a7 I'm
also mindful of the ìiî square
may soon turn into of some rook and pawn
in game night exchange maybe a rook
exchange depending on how black
recaptures Bishop d3 so now they're
going in for the b2 what if I go in for
this
hmm I care about b2
you
and go after their pawns
area
it's a big calculation game
take b2i takes
you have to take my rook
Captur I do have a past pawn
so with the night two minor pieces and a
ruck can I somehow successfully escort
my deep on I keep my eyes open here 9 to
d4 as well but I'm trying to hunt down
the c7 pond they can push I don't even
consider that takes takes Knight to d4
double attack both under a minute
who did not even consider that one okay
I just have to go it's what my instincts
tell me here oh I should have thought a
little bit more about that one
fortunately I have this I don't realize
the bishop was going to go here okay I
didn't I was thinking I had rip to see
one of the previous move that's not the
case so after after g3 there Knoll are
controlling this night here
I could take here there in a fork but
they could also hit me with the fork on
a wacky game
they take
and I pull the trigger on that I just
going to go into D 3 less than 10
it's considering this and then here but
they could take and then the beyond my
night
you
I think that that's a mistake I have to
be very careful now with their king
you
pac-man here I want to help the rook I
get to take b7 and be on their night I'm
going to just take stuff I need time
gainer I am okay they're close to
getting mated
who says closed
my bishop offsets there
okay rook endgame
you
I'm not sure why I did that
like a draw
and
ah they just lost on time
[Music]
well this is clearly an objective draw
[Music]
that's a tough end man
really close final position you know
object just a a goose egg evaluation
Wow did that turn tactical I think I was
better here but you know we were
definitely in bullet mode maybe I should
have just captured straight away and
captured here and maybe not just giving
away my defy pawn so so easily now
they're typing again
you
okay well before I dive in oh no I could
just put on the analysis right here and
yeah
what's a note before I have a look at it
with the engine
I wonder if this is going to be the
suggestion clean 2g5 the safer route is
to simply take here and well
yeah I could take there and maybe I
wonder if I should be playing f4 right
now are waiting first for f5
so to be very delicate because if I play
off four and black gets to establish a
piece on e5 I covered this in a video
not too long ago like within the past
week uploaded to the channel
how f4 simply vacates the e5 square and
then
and one of the game reviews that I did
the Queen was able to make use of the e5
square
but it's a different story if f5 is in
because black would then not be with
there with this nice little Hut for the
king
good shelter soon as I have fond moves
though there's seventh-ranked weaknesses
and the king is weak so we'll definitely
have a okay now I guess the analysis is
done but yeah definitely cut into some
critical line here let's see what the
graph is saying okay
it's was even and then after Knight
takes c7 Bishop takes c7 yeah I was I
was winning then
but did not follow the right way
um yeah I mean it felt really good I
yeah I thought they needed to do this
and what an interesting position right
it's like everything is hanging all for
Brooks this night is hitting everything
what a journey
he has taken by the way right what was
his path here here here here
here here here he sees something this
night what an MVP made a lot of moves
but yeah this was this was necessary
after Bishop takes Knight I guess it's
just gone +2 but I didn't follow up
right oh you know I did think about this
invoice it yeah I should have you know
the knight moves and then these guys are
just going to mop up everything in fact
forget about pawn hunting at this point
with this King moving forward like this
I should black risks getting mated
Bishop couple pawns and two rooks
it's more than enough to weave some kind
of a mate yeah this is one of my first
thoughts one of my first thoughts yeah I
don't know why I didn't pull the trigger
on that you know I lose a little
something with that and then it's uh
it's very equal ish didn't have anything
in this end game but let's look at this
this force line because that's pretty
much the the only thing to have a look
at the opening not much going on yeah I
was I mean I devoted a lot of time in
the opening side I didn't have any I
don't really have anything more to share
right now it's a fan of one of these two
likes Bishop g5 I guess this that idea
to maybe provoke h6 first and only later
play Queen to d2 so this was that what I
was referring to now when I play Queen
to d2 they have to do this but I no
longer have the option to eliminate dark
square bishop
so this is another approach I could have
taken following up with Rick to see one
and an f5 simply supporting my Center on
this advance there's not it's like a
Kings Indian defense Mar del Plata type
position but with a pair of nice
exchanged and the bigger factor is that
there's already the Queen side has
already opened up some
you have a half-open C file and the deep
on is free to move there's there's not a
black pond obstructing the D pons
advance so black always has to be on the
lookout for a push
tonight is going anywhere but d6 there's
this push that I have in mind so that's
another this is another approach think
that this is a good structure for way
so yeah okay Bishop to g5 I went with
Bishop to e3 tanks and yeah well I had
in my mind I wanted to go in for this
dark square Bishop exchange Queen there
is not good because of Bishop g5 but how
can I have followed up better they had
to go in for Knight takes e4 I take the
Queen they take my queen rook F to d1
Bishop h6 it does want to play f4
what did I miss you
after this hang on for a moment what did
I think I thought after I played let's
get these arrows off for a moment I
thought after I played up forward they
would take and after rook takes Knight
they would have f3 attacking my Bishop
attacking my rook what am I missing just
want to try and work out this little
detail because I did think about f4 I
voiced fr B
is that that is far more direct right
here Bishop takes Bishop here the
Knights dead here just cuts off the
coordination immediately here forces I
thought pawn takes pawn but what would I
have then I don't get it
Oh Oh on this capture I just immediately
go to e1 I don't take the knight I just
go here oh man and then that's a that's
simple enough so I had f4 instead of f3
f4 did work but I only looked at
captures takes and then saw that this
would be good and then I shut down the
calculation but I have a different
movement stead of taking the knight as
tempting as that is and it's the thing I
wanted to do for the whole game I was
trying to make that work Bishop to e1
Bishop II won here after a capture and
the knight is lost here push I take with
the pawn and the night is still gone
it's check doesn't amount to anything
he's won next
okay let's just confirm this with the
engine now
arrows on so I did have f4 takes Bishop
II one is the win
that would have
okay I went
three now they have their chance to
rescue the Knight e4 rook e8 f5 can be
met with E 5 so rook e8
Bishop to b5 I didn't consider Bishop to
b5
I just wanted to defend me for okay
I went to d3 f5 and now Knight to b5 hmm
and it just took first took again and
you know just a slight and just nothing
not an advantage really at all night to
b5 here
rook to e1 is another move king of seven
route to e6 what's that about
it's a very odd ball move right to e6
okay you know okay I may be entering on
e7
okay that didn't enter my mind at all
Bishop to F 2 & 9 to b5 maybe I should
have considered that a bit earlier with
it now
yeah I mean we're just a bullet mode at
this point rookie to see one
and they had to go in for a night to d3
here it's winning for me at this point I
should have just gone with route to be
won but I doubled here yeah
what's another thing that I that I could
have thought about at this point instead
of exchanging rooks
proximity of my minor piece to my king
like I have this guy close to my king
he's way out of the ballgame so I should
maybe be pursuing an attack I have him
as a good defender if they're Brooks try
to get you know towards my king he'll be
there to help out a little bit this
night on the other hand he's way out of
the ballgame so it's even considering
this right here but I could insist that
this Knight move away and these guys
should just turn out to be monsters as
mentioned I think I'm close to maybe
weaving some mate against the king you
know like if they do this maybe there's
already some mate certainly a growing
advantage but yeah I don't know if I
have maybe a little bit more time that
this is some some of the reasoning
reasoning that I would use just to go
after the king really keep one more
piece on board and maybe seeing it that
way seeing that their king is more
vulnerable this would have kept and kept
me this would have made me think a bit
more about keeping another piece on the
board that's all okay now it's just upon
advantage and yeah probably a draw I
guess I have something here h3 and okay
yeah right around this point I was
looking just for some some clarity here
I'm really trying to press for something
I guess I have to go for g4 but it's not
even not even upon advantage here
okay and this is very difficult to
convert and in this final position they
dropped on time I'm not sure why I did
this and just allow their King to take
the pawn but in the end I guess there's
nothing I could really do I didn't get
to share it but going here just allow
the check-ins they get the pawn one way
or the other but in the end they drop
down time
a close one I wish I would have spotted
that f4 move but yeah turned turned
tactical and
I missed that
for idea that would have been a nice
spot okay
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below
hope you're having a great day and I
will catch you soon that's all for now
take care bye
you